now is my favorite time of the week the
mailbag first question from
camille hey michael i'm a single woman
in my mid-20s in the dating world
and have a question my mom and men and
women from older generations always talk
about how women hold the power in
relationships and dating
but to me it seems like that power
balance has shifted since our culture
has changed
more women are likely to sleep around
with guys that they aren't in a
relationship with because society is
preaching
sex positivity and this gives away a lot
of the power this type of culture allows
more and more guys to remain single
because it's easy to get what they want
from girls and they are reluctant to put
in the effort for a girl
who would make them wait i know your
opinion on waiting for marriage
but what are your thoughts on the
concept of the power women have and if
you agree that it has shifted more
toward men
sincerely who runs the world no
seriously who
who a reference to my cousin beyonce
you're totally right your intuition is
right older generations would think that
women hold the power because women
women withheld something that men really
really wanted until they got something
out of it
and then feminism convinced them to give
up their leverage
in uh romantic relationships and that
has led to misery for women
and this led to some physical pleasure
for men but i think probably
ultimately misery for men as well and
certainly that power dynamic has shifted
dramatically even now to the point that
some women
who don't want to have sex before
marriage will feel really pressured to
do that because they don't think that
they'll be able to hold on to a guy
because a guy can just move on to any
chickie he wants and get exactly what he
what he desires
so yeah that's a that's a very big
problem i am noticing a little bit of a
shift when you look at young
conservatives
and i don't i don't mean millennials
somehow we always refer to millennials
as the youngest generation we're going
to be 60 and they're going to say oh you
young millennials
but gen z for instance a lot of the the
memes coming out of gen z
a lot of the arguments you hear from
politically astute gen zers
is that they don't just want promiscuous
sex that they don't just want to look at
porn all the time and move on girl girl
to girl and
swipe culture they actually want a
serious relationship
they want to get married they want to
have a family they want to have kids
that that would be the way to stand a
thwart history yelling stop
that the progressive march toward this
drugged up promiscuous
sex-crazed culture would be to say
no to that so you know find one of those
guys i think i think the
the trads as they are called are having
a real ascendancy right now
but but the power has shifted and and so
that there's no denying that
you are at a disadvantage but i wouldn't
be discouraged by that i would i would
i would stand for virtue if you are so
inclined to do that
because i think ultimately that will be
more gratifying even if it's a little
tougher in the dating world right now
hey there i'm glad you like that clip
you can get the whole episode called
getting over self-government here you
don't even
look if you ring the bell and subscribe
you'll get the notifications you won't
need me to tell you
things like this you can go get that
episode you can also get it on apple
podcasts everywhere else you get your
your podcasts
you can also get my book the number one
national best-selling speechless sold
many many more copies than the number
one bestseller
on the new york times list but we're
very proud to be snubbed by the new york
times thank you very much to everyone
who's read it thanks for leaving a
review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you